Huff's Comoros I was a grand Bros a
Stefano finally you're here to put the
ice seriously I waited so long you're
not doing anything you're not even
golden edition sofa
what did you say look what you did look
what you did pity
now what are you gonna do I don't know
they were gonna tell you what to do
you're so cold
all right I have better hide I just want
that oil oh god I'm still something
insane all right sandy point it's
develop snob
Jeremiah fish okay fine I get the
failing is easier though what's the
[ __ ] annoying I can't get in here
no way okay it's about oh [ __ ] the
question is how the [ __ ] Oh Rob Rob
Serrano please talk to him okay okay
yeah I'm in pity
it's I know you hate them but we're just
gonna go and okay I I don't know game
okay okay okay I get it I get it
I kiss your girl from just walls but I
know uh hi I missed I would be pissed
opt-out okay okay
Stefano okay everything is gonna be so
close
haha
oh my god oh my freaking God where are
we
where's the funnel where are we Savan oh
it's not funny oh there he is Jesus
Christ penis Beauty I mean I call the
penis that's funny okay you're crazy man
you're freaking crazy but there go his
girlfriend she was hot don't worry about
it I mean he's he's like so that's why
yeah if you think he's ugly I mean what
anyway okay
by not trusting your players you find I
know I don't want to go in there again
maybe I am supposed to go in there I
gotta leave you there spawn I want to
loot this [ __ ] you're feeling I miss
something
hey this background noise what are you
doing here huh what are you doing here
huh wait you think your towel no all
right good feeling I missed something
there's so much [ __ ] in here
all right fine let's go where's the pond
oh wait oh yes Jesus Christ we do you
have a memory of a flaking goldfish okay
ignore furbelows just focus okay just
focus
Oh what do these do here spot oh uh haha
painting how much for tonight I hate you
okay fine
don't be rude sponsors though okay I
okay
nothing in a barrel snow whatever
whatever
this focus got them barrels okay this
way but be [ __ ] careful Jesus Christ
don't talk to mrs. gel he's a plate I
don't trust him Scully Scully what are
you doing here meeting this Michelle now
we were just talking or just xiong a
beating what French is that a problem
why don't we can't be friends just
because with different people doesn't
mean can be friends huh you think I'm
all different reshares huh like we we
play we play like this Mac well okay I
Miss Piggy I miss him a lot
oh sure if I find pig in this
playthrough Tom O'Mally yeah we're loose
follow share mouth Jeremy Jamm or act
all because both good shamu activate it
oh okay all right
Oh share Mon cher martini jam out just
be [ __ ] quiet our sauce failing men
just been real [ __ ] way
[Music]
okay I think it's good payday oh you're
[ __ ] scared fading how the [ __ ] does
he find me I don't get it
alligators final vada I was getting riot
huh huh
okay okay I'm sorry father I'm really
[ __ ] sorry
[Music]
oh please don't find me
Oh
oh why do you make neither smelly
I have [ __ ] do you sell it you want to
die yeah you're so skull now and I owe
you sir
look yo yo mr. chair this is difficult
everywhere
don't make noise that's the father oh my
god
oh my god waste way see where's that's
crazy son of a [ __ ]
Oh got it get no good perfect I'm happy
happy for you bro okay where should
wife's finest pan out Stefano violence
the violence fun it it's fun it's fun oh
wait oh yes oh yeah yeah I ran no wait
he got me here
[ __ ] it's so dark now okay why are you
sad Stefano come here Stefano wait mr.
chair I helped me find Savannah touching
the floor
touch something was that Savannah yes
all right
oh not again not a [ __ ] again is this
roan afraid oh please
wait I just be quiet Bailey don't make
no sense
I tell you all the [ __ ] time
just be [ __ ] quiet and everything
would be okay okay that's a little
simple shout mode you know it's because
you don't [ __ ] make noise at home up
but what do you know the opposite hey I
remember you dis after day huh
you were so [ __ ] girls that do it
again is he just gonna stay down
I don't get it hello okay
yes don't look at him
okay good good good
now the door is open the safe is clear
not clearly but whatever all right fine
fine fine we can go ah sure mode
activated PA please don't talk to me
alright fine okay I'm near just gotta
push the filing down there and we're
gonna go in here why does it need door
freakin hide doesn't work
alright whatever let's go here this way
left of course why would you go light
seriously though this is crisis stupid
something no now's Vaughn oh uh I don't
want to go in here with even there Oh
pity
be brave do it for me
alright we will find each other again on
the other side alright let's just go
I can't even go though so that was kind
of a big lever okay
okay whatever why don't I don't even
know anymore
that's fauna don't run away from me I
don't pray see how there yes all right
I'm just gonna put him at a safe spot or
something I don't know put you there
buddy while I go and loot [ __ ] this door
has to open don't [ __ ] with me door go
mr. Sherr you you're your mushroom PNA
you mess up in a hat go I didn't worry
pity I'm sorry all right
no it's ears though why can I go here I
have everything right no clue or
anything this is log
don't like this door it feels oppressive
someone on the other side no that makes
no sense I don't know
this door has to open it's the only door
I could remember there's something
different here I don't know makes us
sons but whatever I don't even know I
know oh look in the box
thank you somewhere we perks I love bugs
I thought you're doing getting the way
oh wait there's a door here nah it's not
Thor's bison never any doors I don't I
don't understand
whatever I'm missing I don't know baby
they pay they seriously focus all right
I think I got in here because I really
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
I can favorite no I can't stuff and I'll
see you tomorrow all right
memes the final we'll be back and then
we will know what the [ __ ] we're doing
okay good that sounds good it's okay
with you okay
bye bye
[Music]
we're making everybody